Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Game of Thrones we finally got to see Tyrion’s
Trial, we got to see Mark Gatiss in Braavos
and we got to see an very cool Daenerys moment
from the books.
After the episode all I could think was Game
of Thrones Law and Order.
Quick shout out for the giveaway.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m doing a weekly giveaway just to say
thank you to everyone for being so awesome.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
I’ll pick a random person from the comments
and announce who it is in my Q&A video tomorrow.
So we’re in the back half of the season
so I’m going to do my top 5 moments, then
talk about some of the more important plot
threads and do my review.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Here we go.
Number 5 - The Iron Bank Will Have It’s
Due
It was so awesome to finally get to visit
Braavos, we didn’t see a lot of the city
outside of the Iron Bank, but I talked about
some of the other locations in my bonus video.
I’ll have a link to that at the end.
But the really important take aways from the
Bank Scene are that The Iron Bank is funding
Stannis, not because it cares about Tommen
being a bastard but because the Bank only
trusts Tywin Lannister.
But because he’s in his late 60s he’ll
be gone before the Crown’s debt is paid
back.
And everyone else in King’s Landing is terrible
at managing a kingdom.
So Stannis is the only viable contender for
the throne that actually has the skills to
rule AND, very big AND pay back the debt.
So they give him money to raise another army.
There were so many awesome callbacks to big
events in previous seasons, my favorite was
Mark Gatiss, who’s playing Tycho Nestoris,
calls Davos out for all the ships resting
at the bottom of Blackwater Bay.
Ouch.
One of his sons is down there too ya know.
It was really Davos that did the heavy lifting
in that meeting.
Him showing his missing finger joints was
evidence of Stannis’ commitment to honoring
debts.
I’ll bet if he doesn’t repay the crown’s
debt and what he just borrowed.
The Iron Bank will take his finger joints
just like Stannis took Davos’.
Shout out for Salladhor Saan who’s not our
friend anymore, my friend.
Number 4 - Drogon Destroys the Herd Of Sheep
Really awesome scene from the book but there
was a really big change.
In the book, those bones were of his child.
The picture on my television set was kind
of fuzzy, but I thought I did see a little
boy’s ribcage, but I didn’t see a skull.
And when she offers to pay him for his trouble
there’s nothing on her face that looks like
the regret you have when your baby kills another
baby.
Plus during the actual scene, all we saw was
Drogon crest the hill and burn the goats.
We never saw the boy catch fire.
Even though I don’t think they’re allowed
to do that on television.
Even if they wanted to.
It was a very brief, but very big moment for
establishing that Daenerys’ dragons do as
they please now.
And they’re starting to menace the country.
It’s only going to get worse from here.
Following that up was the first appearance
of Hizdhar zo Loraq who had a very big speaking
role, I think it’s a good sign that he’ll
be back soon.
If you’re not familiar with his character,
he’s the son of one of the former slave
masters.
Those are the wealthy families of the city.
So he has a lot of influence in Meereen.
I’ll talk about him more then next time
he’s in an episode.
If you have read the books, let me know if
you think they should have added a couple
lines about the bones being the goat herder’s
son.
Number 3 - My Name Is Reek
I’ve been waiting so long for him to start
saying that.
Essentially the whole Yara Ironborn invasion
was meant to show us how complete Reek’s
transformation had become.
The Theon that we knew is completely gone.
He’s even forgotten what a Bath is.
And he lives with the dogs and enjoys it.
I really liked how uncomfortable that bath
scene was.
We’re supposed to feel horrified.
The real twist is that Ramsay is going to
use Theon to take back Winterfell.
By playacting as Theon Greyjoy.
Only someone as mad as Ramsay could come up
with a plan like that.
My name is Reek it rhymes with Freak.
Feel free to write your favorite Reek rhymes
in the comments.
Number 2 - Tyrion’s Trial Begins
Because the Trial was so important and so
much was going on I separated it into two
big moments.
My number two is essentially the first montage.
It’s like Cersei found every person at court
that Tyrion ever looked sideways at.
Ser Meryn Trant was getting revenge for Tyrion
threatening him back in Season 2 when Joffrey
was going to shoot Sansa with his crossbow.
Maester Pycelle claims Tyrion stole The Strangler
poison from his stores when he threw him in
the Black Cells, also back in season 2.
Then Cersei spits his Blackwater Joy to Ashes
speech back in his face and Varys talks about
that small council meeting right after the
Red Wedding.
No one is speaking falsely, with the exception
of Pycelle, he never stole poison.
But Tyrion really did say all those things.
and my Number 1 WTF moment - Tyrion Confesses
Tyrion’s outburst really was the best performance
in the episode.
If there’s an acting contest going on between
the cast members, Peter Dinklage just won
it.
And just to be clear, he wasn’t confessing
to killing Joffrey.
That was another change from the books.
On the show, he just causes a huge scene and
demands trial by combat.
Remember, that’s how he met Bronn in the
Eyrie in season 1.
But that throws Jaime’s bargain with Tywin
out the window.
The interesting thing here is that one, Shae
is clearly being manipulated by Cersei to
lie.
Did you see how many times she glanced at
her during her speech?
And two, Tywin is so rigid in sticking to
the rules that he can’t save Tyrion.
He has to allow the Trial by combat to commence.
He really was going to uphold his bargain
with Jaime.
And that’s why I love Game of Thrones so
much.
It’s like one character or a group of characters
comes up with a really good plan to save the
day.
And one person just says Fuck It, and things
just go to shit.
It’s how Ned Stark ended up losing his head.
Remember, in that instance Joffrey was the
one that went rogue.
It was how Theon got into trouble when he
left to sack Winterfell.
He could have just stayed and been a prince
for the rest of his life.
But nope.
So let this be a lesson, if you’re a character
on Game of Thrones.
And you’re part of some elaborate plan.
Do not go rogue.
Stick to the plan.
So let me know what you’re biggest WTF moment
was.
Tyrion’s confession?
Stannis in Braavos?
Or just seeing what’s happening to Reek.
It really is depressing to watch his scenes
this season.
Just so horrible.
The only real plot line that we need to remember
that I didn’t already mention is Oberyn
Martell’s secret mission to kill the Mountain.
There was a nice shoutout for Team Fuck The
King in that small council meeting too.
I just love that Varys actually said it out
loud.
There is now a bounty on The Hound.
So more people will be trying to kill him.
They don’t know Arya is with him.
Oberyn was one of the few people at Tyrion’s
trial that was impartial, and his ears really
perked up when he heard Trial by Combat.
We have seen scenes of him fighting in the
trailer.
So that sounds like it’s right around the
corner.
If there’s any big plot threads I missed
just add them in the comments.
Overall the episode was another solid A. All
of the actors were amazing and Mark Gatiss
was so much fun as Mycroft in Braavos.
I really hope he comes back soon.
Peter Dinklage was really the home run of
the episode.
He did an interview where he and Nikolaj Coster-Waldau
talked about joking around while they were
filming that trial scene.
Because it was so emotionally demanding on
them, they tried to blow off steam by burning
a few takes skipping down the aisle and laughing.
But the funny part was that the whole crew
just looked daggers at them and no one on
set laughed.
They work like 18 hours a day when they shoot,
so who can blame them for getting upset when
actors waste time?
I’ve been so impressed this season with
how the producers have been able to include
all these Holy Shit moments without things
getting out of control.
It’s like we’re getting four or five Blackwater
level episodes instead of just one or two.
Also, they’ve even started scouting locations
for season 5.
I’ll talk about that in another video.
In the teaser for episode 7 we saw the new
mountain, so we’ll get to see Tyrion’s
trial by combat and it looks like Sansa gets
another peek at the Moon Door.
So be sure to subscribe to get my video.
My Q&A will post tomorrow night like normal.
So leave me any questions you had about the
episode.
Right now click here to get that video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And click here to learn all about Braavos.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!